[Music]
hello again you're watching the press
preview it's a first look at what is on
those front pages as they arrive in the
next half an hour we're going to be
seeing what is making the headlines
that's with the editor of the sheffield
star nancy fielder and annabelle denham
as well from the institute of economic
affairs but first let's take a look at
what is on some of those front pages
well the express leads with a pledge
that's made by the conservative
leadership candidate rishi sunak to save
local businesses and the high streets
according to the observer richie sunak
is being urged to change his tactics in
the conservative leadership race before
it's too late
well the mirror leads with the story
claiming that rishi sunak had a private
pool built that's amid the cost of
living crisis
and the telegraph highlights which she
soon acts vow to put a 10 pound fine in
place for people who miss their nhs
appointments
meanwhile the sunday times claims that
prince charles accepted one million
pounds from the family of osama bin
laden clarence house denies he's
personally involved and says the money
was paid to the prince of wales
charitable trust
hot as hell well that is the star's
warning that the summer heat wave could
extend until the end of october
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you'll see on the screen
during the program you can check out all
of the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us while we talk about
them and we're joined tonight by nancy
fielder and annabelle denham good
evening to both of you thank you for
spending your saturday night with us
let's talk
about
the tory leadership race front page of
the express a lot of commentators seem
to be saying that rishi needs to pull a
game changer out of the bag
what do you reckon
nancy is this it
well this could potentially be it i mean
all of our cities sheffield is awful at
the minute the city center it's on its
knees and all the issues are mentioned
here your empty shops your banks closing
your hooligans causing problems that
sort of aggressive begging they're not
unique to sheffield all of our city
centres and lots of our town centres
suffer these but there's just no detail
here if you're going to make promises at
least say how you're going to make them
happen and we just seem to be getting
promises left right and center he knows
this is something that is a massive
issue so it's great that he wants to
tackle it but actually how is he going
to do it because if it was an easy one
to solve it would have happened and what
is it going to do to make sure that the
big stores all the massive names that we
know your debenhams john lewis's clothes
lots of branches all these empty shops
in the middle of sheffield and
everywhere else how's he magically going
to change that i don't see anything that
says he's going to but yeah it's a good
talking point because people want it to
change but i've hear no solution yeah
there's been review after review hasn't
there about what to do about the high
street and empty shots and so on
does it give the impression to you
annabelle that he's floundering around a
bit to come up with some some good ideas
certainly i think if the student
campaign are not careful then they're
going to be faced with accusations of of
desperation
really throwing so much red meat at the
tory voter base that one has to wonder
how much of it they would be able to
follow through were wishy to be
voted in as tory leader and prime
minister um you know his his campaign
really is on the ropes there's a very
strong sense that uh liz trusts the
momentum is with liz truss
from
you know it's the tv appearances it's
the hustings um it's even her economic
policies and let's not forget she's
going to head to head with a former
chancellor where she's coming out um on
top so you can understand why rishi
sunak has come out uh with this promise
to revitalize our beleaguered high
street certainly it's going to be a
popular idea but as nancy says it is
very thin uh on detail you know i i
actually personally am quite bullish on
the high street i think that too many
commentators are quite gloomy about its
prospects but i think what we need is
for the government to stop trying to
level the playing field bit through
taxing online companies or
tweaking at the margins and that seems
to be what rishi sunaka's is offering
here with uh clamp downs on on littering
and
uh and hooligans i'm not sure that's
really going to make a difference
between whether some of our retail
giants are going to survive the coming
months and years or not yeah well let's
move on to the front of the sunday times
nancy um
some pledges from liz truss
about equaling up opportunities with
universities specifically oxbridge what
do you what do you make of her plans
so i actually love this idea so her i
mean she comes from leeds she went to
school and leads and she's basically
saying not every teacher supports bright
kids not all kids who get a stars get
a chance to go to oxford or cambridge
because they're not supported their
aspirations aren't raised it's a whole
different system to apply you have to
apply earlier and i do think the idea of
a letter which is what she's suggesting
coming from the top two universities
saying you know what you could apply and
you should apply would be really good
the reality of whether oxford and
cambridge can take all these children
is
completely lifted across it obviously
couldn't happen it's not even take it's
not even just taking them is it nancy is
it saying that they'll get an interview
now that would that would mean that
oxbridge would have to interview the
out of
13 000 people who've got those straight
a's that any of those who wanted to
they'd have to interview is that
practical
no it's another pie in the sky idea
which sounds fantastic but also
fundamentally too many of our children
never get to the stage where they can
even achieve a levels or even reach a
levels so this is great let's raise
aspirations but there are much more
fundamental issues that actually should
be grabbing the headlines and she wants
to be the education prime minister that
she's building herself as really really
fundamentally our schools are massively
failing lots of children and they all
need to be picked up this isn't about
creating an elite it needs to be about
people
you mentioned elite it's also a reminder
that both of these candidates are oxford
alumni themselves both studied the same
degree ppe um
you know how how in touch are they
annabelle do you think
well i don't need your questions to be
asked about that nancy is absolutely
right that
it's quite late in the educational
journey for the government to be making
some kind of intervention and in terms
of being out of touch that accusation
has been leveled against um certainly
rishi soon over the course of this
campaign as we saw uh or perhaps we'll
discuss on the cover of the mirror about
uh the swimming pool that he is
installing uh at huge uh cost um yet
instinctively you know it's it's a nice
idea for
um more pupils particularly those from
poorer backgrounds to get the
opportunity to go to some of our great
higher education institutions um but you
know oxbridge colleges are independent
private entities which set their own
admission criteria so
as far as i understand it this would
make them part of the state apparatus
and that is the kind of measure that uh
liz trust has come out quite strongly
against she wants to make the state
smaller she wants to um deregulate all
of which i'm
in favor of and i think it begs the
question you know this leadership
contest is absorbing so much time and
energy among some of our most senior
politicians and i just wonder over the
course of the next few a few weeks or
indeed months who really is is running
the country i appreciate the parliament
is in recess but liz trust is our
foreign secretary and there's a war
going on in europe so i just wonder
where the attention is and whether too
much focus really is being given to what
i think is a pretty insane way of
choosing a new leader yeah well you can
question whether boris johnson is ruling
the country it's his wedding party
tonight isn't it i don't know if you've
seen any of the pictures uh nancy of
those celebrations and people arriving
absolutely and look you wouldn't want to
stop anybody from having a wedding party
no matter how many times they've been
married but i think i mean how many
parties
yeah absolutely having a party at this
time we've got huge crisis at home um
there's a war in ukraine there were so
many so many issues there people our
food banks are the only thing that seems
to be blossoming
and barry is having his wedding party
but then let's hope maybe tomorrow
morning he'll get up and crack on with
the job until we get a new prime
minister
well let's talk a little bit more about
rishi sunak front of sunday telegraph a
10 pound fine for an nhs no show of
course fixing the nhs has got to be top
of the
top of the list of priorities hasn't it
um
or one of them for whoever becomes prime
minister nancy what do you think of this
pledge
so again i think when you go to the
doctors and you see the posters on the
wall saying
we've had hundreds of missed
appointments people just not showing up
it does make you angry it does make you
annoyed
i am very suspicious of any plans to
charge with nhs because i think we all
remember when prescriptions were free
well maybe we don't maybe i'm just
getting old and and you could get
dentist treatment for all these things
it's a gradual gradual
ladder of privatization and i want
people to turn up for the appointments i
think people should have the decency to
cancel appointments at the very least to
not come in but i don't think that
charging is the way to do it and i also
think it will probably hit the people
who are
really really busy at work or on of
their own shifts that they're not
allowed off of at the last minute or
child care issues i'm not sure this is
going to target the right people and i
don't see it as a good way to bring your
money to health service yeah good luck
with administering that as as well um
front page of the observer
annabelle and yet another endorsement
this evening
for uh liz trust from
north former northern ireland secretary
brandon lewis um front of the observer
saying that his team are basically
urging him to change tactics before it's
too late those ballot papers are going
out
yes the clock is ticking uh the ballot
papers are going out next week and rishi
really is running out of time to turn
this oil tanker around
as i said earlier the momentum really
does seem to be with liz trust she has
these endorsements from uh senior
members of the conservative party tom
teugenhart writing in the times today
giving her his backing now brandon lewis
and nadine zahawi who himself had thrown
his hat in the ring uh expected to throw
his support behind liz trusts uh in the
coming
days so you could you can understand why
the formula chancellor is being urged to
change tact to change uh tactics um
you know
in on almost every
metric
liz trust is ahead in the polling of the
membership and that that being said
annabelle sorry to interrupt that being
said do you think he'll stay the course
with this leadership race
given that given the direction of travel
i i can't see him
suddenly you know attacking in a
completely different direction now um
he's come comes under some criticisms in
this article over his very slick social
media uh persona that the fact that he's
really focused on on social media
content on the tv appearances of course
he spoke to andrew neal last night
whereas liz trust declined uh that
interview and he's being urged to to
visit uh swing voters to really dedicate
time um to the old brother he's being
urged not to visit swing voters and
really dedicate his time to the
conservative uh grassroots but you know
we know from history that those once
those ballot papers go out they do tend
to be returned quite quite quickly so
like i say the clock really is ticking
and i i'm just not sure he's going to be
able to do enough in the time that he
has left all right well we've managed to
spend 10 minutes talking about the tory
leadership race having said
that we weren't going to devote that
much time to it don't go away plenty
more for us to talk about after
the break including of course how could
we neglect this story will england be
able to lift their first major trophy
since
1966 tomorrow night the pressure is on
for those lionesses do stay with us
[Music]
hello again you're watching the press
preview uh with me again are the editor
of the sheffield star nancy fielder and
annabelle denham from the institute of
economic affairs
welcome back to both of you now i don't
know if either of you are football fans
but please tell me uh nancy that you're
going to be watching the lionesses
tomorrow evening
i absolutely will with the whole family
including my two boys one of whom is
completely obsessed by football and just
as obsessed with the wonderful lionesses
as he ever is with any big male england
matches it's so exciting and i think we
talk a lot about how this has to create
access for girls to play football of
course it must we have to raise their
aspiration we have to open the doors for
them but actually the message this is
sending to our boys that women are not
only good at football but they are in a
really massive final it's so important i
think this is just a message for
everybody isn't it just absolutely get
behind isn't it just and annabelle you
know we've we talk a lot don't we ever
every time the men's team gets close
everybody starts to start singing it's
coming home and yet it could be the
women who end up beating germany at
wembley in front of 90 000 people
yes and how how wonderful that would be
a triumph for england is wonderful
anyway but it really would be quite
something if it's the lionesses who who
deliver it obviously this tournament has
been great for the women's game i think
we have in recent years perhaps been to
resistance to to change when it comes to
women's sport but if you just look at
the viewing figures and how they have
surged particularly in the last six
twelve months four women's football i
think changes is it has happened it's
not even underfoot anymore underwear
anymore it really has happened um it's
on the covers of all of our newspapers
uh tomorrow um and you know enormous
people a number of people will be tuning
in i will try and catch some of it i
don't watch a lot of football uh myself
certainly uh i watched the eurid delayed
euro 2020s last year when uh we were at
victory with we've
italy beat us on penalties and that nail
biting and very ultimately very
disappointing uh match so so let's hope
that tomorrow it comes out with a more
positive response for uh england and i
think that the bookies do have england
as slight favorites so let's hope
they're right and we need a good news
story don't we nancy i'm i'm i you can't
see but i'm willing them on in my own
quiet way i've got a little lioness
badge which i'm not gonna take off i
think i'll pin it to my nightie tonight
not take it off until after they've
played that match but we need something
good
what they've already achieved is
phenomenal that squad not a very large
squad of women in this country and what
our grounds bramall lane was one of them
right across the country and what the
cities have done to back them what has
been achieved there is absolutely
priceless so yeah we really really want
to win but my goodness what a journey
it's already been and you're quite right
you're quite right to point that out
it's just extraordinary isn't it for
them to be there a lot of the credit
being given to the dutch coach serena
vegan
yeah she's done she's done an absolutely
fantastic job i suspect she wouldn't
take the credit herself though she would
share out amongst the team but she is
just a fantastic leader isn't she she
gets them in the right mood she takes on
the teams that they're not expected to
beat but they have got the home crowds
behind them and the country's done the
whole country a world of good we could
really do with some some more of that
winning spirit tomorrow and just final
word from you annabelle what do you
reckon the score line will be tomorrow
well i i just couldn't possibly say i
think you know england and germany
obviously came at this tournament from
very different ends of uh the spectrum
england were considered favorites while
germany were you know suspected to be a
team of four glory so both have made it
into the final it could be an extremely
close match i couldn't say what i think
the final score might be but certainly
you know it's very inspirational i think
to young girls and liz trust has talked
a lot over the course of the last few
days about how
we're too willing in this country to
walk in uh talk the united kingdom down
or talk england down in the case of of
the football but you know i think that
this this could be the good news story
that that we've all been hoping for uh
mid and uh other very and
you know that is why you are a news
pundit because you managed to shoehorn
the tory leadership
back into our discussion about the
lionesses there